[Music]  intono is completely free to use to  install antenna on your mobile go to the  Apple App Store or Google Play Store  search for antenna  look for the orange logo then tap  install after a few moments antenna will  be ready to use  [Music]  the first thing to do with an 10o is to  add a place an easy place to start with  is your home address tap add places as  you start typing your home address  Google Maps shouldn't find your address  Google seems to think that most of the  gor Township is in East Gore so don't  worry if your address is east coy even  though you live in north or west gore  give your address a nickname such as hon  after a few moments you'll receive a  welcome post and any other posts that  are currently relevant to the place you  have added you can add other locations  such as your work your children's school  local parks or other locations that  you're interested in keeping up to date  with